Salut les Mentalos !
Apprendre à faire pleins de choses mentalement c'est super bien.
Mais rester concentré pour pouvoir le faire c'est beaucoup mieux.
Fin août je suis allé faire la première partie de Vérino en testant un nouveau numéro, et devant les 300 personnes, je me suis retrouvé complètement bloqué.
Pas durant tout le sketch, c'était pas forcément le trac.
C'est le moment où je devais rentrer en introspection j'ai pas réussi à le faire instantanément.
J'ai mis 3 minutes pour ça. C'est long 3 minutes devant 300 personnes.
Ce que j'essayais de faire sur scène c'est quelque chose que j'arrive à faire en 3 secondes à la maison.
C'est pas compliqué !
La seule chose que je n'ai pas faite ce jour là, c'est de me concentrer avant de monter sur scène, de me concentrer réellement.
Peu importe les gens, peu importe le bruit, peu importe tout !
Le lendemain j'ai refait le même numéro et y a eu aucun problème.
La seule différence entre les deux jours c'est que le lendemain, j'ai pris quelques secondes pour me concentrer avec une vraie méthode de concentration.
Ça m'a permis de me focaliser sur l'instant présent et cette méthode de concentration, aujourd'hui, j'en fais un petit Master Class pour la partager avec vous.
La première chose à faire c'est d'utiliser une technique de respiration qui va réduire un petit peu le stress,
qui va réduire les pensées négatives, c'est une technique de respiration dont on se sert en sophrologie,
mais y en a pleins d'autres, celle-ci elle est très efficace.
Tout l'exercice vous le faites uniquement par le nez en fermant bien la bouche.
Tout d'abord vous allez inspirer à fond à fond à fond, sans chercher à gonfler le ventre, vous remplissez un maximum.
Vous remplissez jusqu'à remplir toute la cage thoracique, ça doit prendre au moins 4 ou 5 secondes.
Et ça va détendre tous les nerfs de la cage thoracique, ça va réduire toutes les tensions.
Vous gardez l'air pendant 2 ou 3 secondes au moins.
Et ensuite vous expirez à fond, vraiment très fort, tout par le nez.
Durant 5 ou 6 secondes ; vous cherchez à vider complètement, l'intégralité de vos poumons.
Vous attaquez ensuite une phase de repos de 2 ou 3 secondes.
C'est à dire que vous allez recommencer le processus.
Mais vous n'allez pas inspirer toute de suite à la fin de l'expiration,
vous allez inspirer au moment où vous sentirez que vous avez besoin d'inspirer.
Vous ne forcez pas la respiration.
Donc il peut se passer 2 ou 3 secondes avant de réinspirer.
Et vous faites ça 2 ou 3 fois d'affilée.
À la fin de cette étape vous serez déjà beaucoup moins dispersé mentalement, et ça vous aura pris à peine une minute, même un peu moins.
Deuxièmement, avant de commencer la chose importante qui vous demande de vous concentrer, que ce soit un cours, un travail ou en représentation, peu importe ce que c'est ce que vous avez à faire,
Evitez les discussions inutiles, et commencez à vous isoler un petit peu. quelques secondes.
C'est juste pour faire un espèce de sas, entre le futile et le moment où vous allez devoir être concentré.
Faites un point mentalement sur ce que vous avez à faire, pourquoi vous devez être concentré, quel est le but de cette concentration...
Fermez les yeux quelques secondes, comme s'il n'existait plus que vous et le but à atteindre via cette concentration, vous les réouvrez. Go ! C'est parti.
Et troisième étape, la concentration, sa passe par l'attention.
Simplementpar l'attention.
Donc vous allez faire un exercice qui aide à développer son attention.
Plus vous ferez cet exercice là dans votre vie, plus ce sera facile de vous mettre dans un état de concentration extrême très rapidement.
Perso, je le fais en 3 phases. Ca peut se faire en plus. Mais en 3 phases ça va.
Je le fais aussi les yeux fermés, je vous conseille de faire ça.
C'est beaucoup mieux pour bien s'isoler.
Vous allez imaginer deux rails de train, qui sont parallèles. Comme si devant vous, à vos pieds il y a avait deux rails de train qui partaient loin dans une plaine.
Parallèles.
Vous regardez bien les rails de train mentalement. Quand je dis "vous regardez ces rails là" c'est mentalement.
Et vous essayez de continuer à visualiser, tout en imagineant ce qu'ils vont faire, jusqu'au bout, jusqu'à l'horizon, jusqu'à temps qu'ils se rejoignent en un seul point.
Prenez le temps de le faire, prenez le temps de bien visualiser.
Ensuite, ouvrez les yeux, respirez un bon coup, refermez les yeux, et c'est reparti.
Vous allez dessiner mentalement dans le vide, le symbole de l'infini.
Mais pas avec votre doigt, comme je suis en train de le faire, même si vous pouvez le faire au départ pour vous aider.
Mais juste mentalement.
Comme si il y avait un point lumineux qui partait de quelque part devant vous.
Dans le noir, toujours, les yeux fermés !
Et vous lui faites tracer à ce point lumineux, le symbole de l'infini et vous essayez de repasser dessus, deux, trois, quatre, cinq fois, jusqu'à temps de bien le voir devant vous.
Et pour terminer, vous imaginez un tableau devant vous. Un tableau effaçable, ou un tableau à craie devant vous, et vous allez visualiser votre main en train d'écrire le mot "mental".
Donc vous écrivez "mental", mentalement, sur le tableau.
Une fois que vous visualisez bien le mot "mental", juste à cette fois là, alors vous effacez le L pour ne voir plus que "menta".
Mais prenez le temps de le faire, toujours. Il ne faut pas que ça aille vite.
Il faut que vous visualisiez bien ce qu'il se passe.
Une fois que vous êtes sûr de bien voir que "menta", alors vous allez effacer le A, puis après vous allez effacer le T, puis le N, puis le E, jusqu'à temps que vous effaciez tout.
Et vous savez quoi, vous serez prêts, vous serez dans un état d'attention et de concentration extrême à ce moment là.
Vous serez beaucoup plus focus, sans vous laisser parasiter par tout ce qui se passe.
Plus on pratique ces exercices, plus on arrive à les faire rapidement. Moi il me faut à peu près 1 minute 30 pour faire tout ça.
Et je le fais systématiquement avant de monter sur scène, pour mon spectacle, parce que là je ne l'avais pas fait.
D'ailleurs je joue mon spectacle demain à la Garnenne-Colombes, demain soir.
"Et les autres villes, c'est quand que tu passes ?!" [imite les abonnés]
Je vous mets un lien dans le descriptif vers mon site Internet, il y a toutes les dates.
N'oubliez pas de mettre un pouce en l'air en bas de la vidéo si vous l'avez trouvé utile, c'est important.
Merci également de l'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout.
Bien sûr, abonnez vous avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !
[musique]